again hello and welcome to all of you
that are joining this program dedicated
to metagenomics now before we start
talking about metagenomics itself I want
to mention a little bit about the onyx
logic programs the Allman's logic
programs are designed to introduce non
bioinformaticians and people that are
not coming from an engineering
necessarily backgrounds to the
complexities and the opportunities with
onyx data in biomedical research as well
as all life sciences we believe that
today biology is moving forward with a
lot more data being generated then we
have the capacity to analyze so it's a
priority for us to enable the future
generation of biologists with tools that
they can use to solve this challenge of
big data so we're excited to set up a
series of programs that are focused on
different types of data and this program
specifically is going to be focused on
metagenomics now what is meta genomics
meta essentially is a prefix that stands
for collection of different elements
that comprise a single entity so a lot
of times you might hear words like
meta-analysis which means analyzing data
from multiple sources or analyzing
perhaps something that was published in
a variety of different publications
metagenomics really talks about a
collection of genomes a collection of
genomics it is of course talking on
genomic data so a collection of genomic
data about different organisms and a lot
of times when people speak about
metagenomics we're really talking about
micro organisms now micro organ
are much more abundance in the world
than macro organisms like humans and
other species and so the field of
metagenomics is a field that has been
rapidly evolving ever since the microbes
were first discovered when we had
microscope and the microscope was
invented and today we have a new level
of detail that is possible due to
availability of genomic data so this
program is a two month program that will
start in November and will last all the
way till the end of December giving all
of the participants the opportunity to
understand the different challenges and
opportunities in metagenomics as well as
to have hands-on experience working with
data metagenomic data that you will
learn how to analyze how to interpret
biologically the meaning of the analysis
and then also to demonstrate your
capability by designing a project of
your own now we're not expecting
everybody to necessarily come to develop
a project of their own but we are
excited about the types of projects that
participants of previous programs have
been able to develop as they
participated in the program
so this Onix logic program is starting
today and this is one of the free
sessions and we are doing this session
to encourage people to understand what
the program is all about how it will
help them wherever they are in their
journey
and what are some of the topics that we
will cover so we'll really explore the
role microbes play in human wellbeing
health and disease and we have really
worked hard at designing this program to
be available fully online and to be
rewarding to students and all the way to
experienced researchers that can utilize
the types of data and the analysis
methods to get biological in
out of this high quality high-throughput
data we plan to cover two major topics
in metagenomics one of them is the
analysis of 16s and 18s ribosomal RNA
that can allow us to study the hyper
variable regions and understand
composition of the microbial community
when we talk about 16s RNA but also
we'll talk about other types of
microbial genomes and we'll talk about
genomics in the context of an
understanding how these different
strains of viruses and bacteria interact
with environmental challenges and
develop and how can we study that using
genomic data so we are starting today
with an overview of the program so what
we really want to talk about are two
things we want to talk about
expectations what might you expect from
participating in this program and talk a
little bit more about the schedule and
deadlines and important dates of this
program so what we will do is we will
meet online just like today to cover a
variety of topics and typically we will
go from more theoretical topics to then
more and more practical where we will
learn how to analyze data and we will
have a chance to review specific data
sets these data sets are all going to be
from the public domain so everybody will
be able to read the publication about
how the data was generated understand
why the data was generated analyze the
data and then compare the results to
what the authors of the publication
showed in their methods section so
really the program is going to cover a
variety of theoretical background
information with some practical skills
practical ways to analyze data and then
also conceptually how to think about
different types of
that are possible with this kind of data
so we will talk about like I mentioned
before online sessions practical and
they are going to be supplemented by
online materials that you will have
access to on our educational platform or
portal where you can find a variety of
different projects and a variety of
different online lessons and really
learn on your own schedule
now some of the topics that we will go
through include understanding the
microbiome how microbial communities
live and function together and how they
affect agriculture organ function and
health so we'll talk about the microbial
community and how it functions we'll
talk about sequencing including 16s and
18s ribosomal RNA sequencing but also
genomic sequencing next-generation
sequencing in general and how the
development of these methods are really
allowing us to understand better the
microbial communities and what is this
understanding actually produced how can
we apply this understanding of the way
the microbes live and work together
between themselves and with the host how
can we apply and use that information
then we'll talk about several ways to
analyze metagenomic data so there are
two main aspects of analysis of
metagenomic data where we will talk
about the challenge of accurate assembly
of a meta-genome a genome of a specific
for example variation a species for
example as you know in viruses there's
this concept of quasi species really a
diverse population of the same specie
but that has a lot of variants and so
therefore they are not represented by
single genomes like we typically think
of human as the human genome well if you
talk about Ebola or you talk about flu
you're really talking about a community
of genome
and we can still study this community of
genomes by looking at the variation at
the genomic level understanding that
there's a representative of a population
that we are looking at and we will talk
about the non genome based metagenomics
so really metagenomics as analysis of
the microbial community based on their
variability so we'll look at genome
composition in a sample understanding
that this is a sample coming from a
whole variety of species that work and
live together and function together and
so we are looking at their function as
an entity as a microbiome and so we'll
then understand the microbiome and how
it really functions and how we can study
variation in composition as well as
variation at the genomic level to
understand infectiousness or different
phenotypes related to infectious
diseases we'll talk about phenotypes
that are related to for example how much
fruit a certain plant produces based on
rice or bacteria how infectious and how
fast the disease spreads based on
genomic understanding of the genome
variation as well as how can we link the
composition of the microbiome for
example with a stress response or some
kind of a well-being or a healthy versus
sick condition as well as how do we
understand resistance to different drugs
including resistance to antibiotics so
those are some of the topics that we
will cover and for each one of these
topics we will provide you with an
example a data set that could be studied
in the context of that topic so for
example we will have several projects
each project is taken from a publication
so we'll have access to the protocol of
how they generated the data how they
sequence the data how they analyze the
data what are the conclusions from
analysis and we can repeat the same
steps to really understand what we can
learn and how can leverage that example
to think of similar types of studies one
big aspect of metagenomics and the
popularity of metagenomics is the
emergence of 16s metagenomic sequencing
so amplified 16s ribosomal RNA
sequencing has really reduced
significantly the cost of sequencing and
therefore study of a microbiome so in
November in November we will start by
talking about the aspects of sequencing
how does this sequencing really work so
we will talk about how this could be a
very low or moderately costly study it
really focuses on a 1,500 base region
that could be extracted and then
amplified to sequence either the full
typically the full sequence across the
whole sample and you can therefore study
this hyper variable region that can
provide species specific signature that
are very useful for bacterial
identification so those are some of the
methods of sequencing where you can look
at amplicon of just specific regions of
16s ribosomal RNA you can study the
whole length of 16s ribosomal RNA or you
can also even do the full genomic kind
of standard sequencing without
amplifying anything and we'll look at
different examples of how these
different types of sequencing methods
can be used in the context of these
studies when it comes to sequencing the
hyper variable region we're really
talking about a portion of the ribosome
so we're talking about the RNA that
encodes the bottom part of the ribosome
when it sits on the
RNA and we will look at how these
different regions so you can see those
regions over here on this side this is
for e.coli you can look how these
regions could be used to very
specifically understand the composition
of the microbiome they are highly
conserved within the species and
therefore and they're pretty short and
so therefore you can sequence a lot of
them so you can have good coverage and
at the same time they are very fairly
well annotated so instead of trying to
assemble whole genomes of different
representatives of species within your
sample you're able to just use a
database and then learn about the
composition and the different
proportions of species phyla and family
within your sample so that's when we
will talk about the microbe the
microbiome as a functional bacterial
community so really the microbiome is a
composition of fungi bacteria and
viruses it's essentially all the
microorganisms in a single sample that
it has stable condition within a
specific environment so this could be an
ecological sample so sample from water
or dirt it could be a sample from the
gut for example or it could be a fecal
sample so we we think of the microbiome
as a functional community it has a
specific set of functions and it is
really defined by the microbiome stable
condition and so we will also look at
how the stable condition can change as a
result of different environmental
factors for example we can think of the
food the intake of nutrient the
processing of that food inside the human
gut as being a process that is
really stable and it could be disrupted
by the change in diet so one of the
projects that we will look at is
actually how does the changing of diet
even when it is not long-term exposure
to really change its the physiology of
the host but a short term a kind of
transplantation of a microbiome can
change behavior and so this is a very
interesting area that really points to
the functional aspect of the microbiome
the microbiome can really in the gut the
microbiome in the gut can affect the way
that we function we think we interact
and that's a fairly new area that is
being studied now in terms of the
microbiome now the microbiome actually
has these stable communities in a
variety areas around our body and we can
study them as these stable communities
so skin microbiome vaginal microbiome
gut microbiome different types of micro
biomes and so now you can think of those
as ways to study how different processes
occur that are very critical to human
health right we talk about for example
skin diseases and we talk about the oral
microbiome and aspects of oral cancers
or dentistry and things like that we can
talk about the gut microbiome and how it
relates to intake of food ability to
process specific types of food and of
course how that affects our response to
different treatments because of course a
lot of the treatments come through the
gut so we take pills and then through
the stomach that get into the
bloodstream right so a lot of that has
to do with that functional microbial
community so we can use a database that
essentially tells us how taxonomic
classification of these different micro
organisms can essentially work together
you can see here composition of
different types of bacteria how the
composition could be studied to
understand the health and the processes
the functionality of these so to say
organs the microbiomes
associated with different parts of the
body and so we will look at different
examples that will help us understand
how this actually works now there are
some challenges associated with analysis
of such data a lot of these challenges
are related to the understanding of how
sequencing actually works and so
sequencing when we sequence these hyper
variable regions we will have a
challenge of aligning the short reads
and then making sure that so typically
this is paired and reads so we have more
reliability of the sequence itself but
nevertheless there are a number of
methods that have been designed to
address some of these challenges how to
identify properly reads that were
aligned correctly how to identify the
hyper variable regions correctly how to
map them to the database which database
to use how do we create these
organizational taxonomic units or own to
use and how do we really then use that
composition based on these Oh to use
using clustering techniques etc so those
are challenges related to the 16s
ribosomal RNA but also we'll talk about
other challenges if you take a sample
and you sequence total army what are
some of the challenges there with
assembly with k-mers so really assembly
of genome entities that are not
necessarily mentioned in databases so
we'll talk about some of those
challenges as well and it's going to be
very important for us to really
understand again the theoretical aspects
of what these challenges are but then
also to look at practical examples how
do we use in a
practical sense this or another type of
data and how do we go from sequencing
the data mapping the data on some
database or on a collection of genomes
and then actually getting some
biologically meaningful information that
is significant enough for us to say
something about something like the
health of the gut or some of these other
examples that we talked about so as I
said there is a variety of different
databases that are available to do so so
we have different databases like
Greenjeans
Silva NCBI NCBI of course hosts a lot of
data that has been submitted on a
variety of different genomes but just
taking all of the genomes and mapping
everything that we have in a read on
those genomes you know there's going to
be a lot of overlap so the data is going
to be noisy so some of these databases
were actually more curated and validated
biologically to help us reduce the
amount of noise that we have in our data
and we'll look at some of those examples
where we will compare the different
databases and really try to run our
analysis so that we understand in which
case which database which reference
database is going to be more useful so
we'll have a whole session dedicated to
kind of a review of some of these
databases and we will particularly look
at how to compare the results so Silva
for example is a comprehensive online
resource for quality checked and aligned
ribosomal RNA sequence data which is
important because it really validates a
lot of these so biologically actually
uses the sequences that are in the
database to make sure that biologically
this works and this is an important
aspect because we will look at how a lot
of noisy data coming from the
availability of this genomic sequencing
can actually be more confuse
using because of chimeras and because of
the different wrong assembly of
organizational and taxonomic units now
on the other hand we will also look at
examples of specific projects developed
by NCBI and FDA and other regulatory
agencies that actually are more focused
on detection presence or absence of
specific species that are had that have
been understood as being harmful to a
specific process so an important aspect
of that is really taking and looking at
the database design from the standpoint
of how it is going to be used so we'll
take a look at some of those examples
now way to apply practically and then
this type of understanding this type of
knowledge about how the sequencing works
and the types of data that you can
generate is to actually try and run a
pipeline so the data too is a good
example of a pipeline that is
specifically designed to address a lot
of the challenges that we talked about
up until now related to 16s ribosomal
amplicon sequencing so we'll take a look
at that pipeline and we will apply it to
a number of different projects to
understand how it addresses some of
these challenges that we discussed and I
want to mention how the program is built
around like I mentioned theoretical
concepts project examples and some
practical tools now a lot of times you
will find that courses require kinds of
installation of software and really a
variety of different packages and that's
where a lot of programs fail at this so
we would we would like to believe that
our program has addressed that challenge
very efficiently by putting all of the
packages that are required behind a
visual interface that is easy to use now
this is a functional usable interface
that you can apply to a
in projects that we will go through you
can apply to public domain projects that
you will source from places like NCBI
and you can also use it for your own
data it's a fully developed research
platform so I want to talk a little bit
about that platform so that we can
understand how it works so the program
itself is going to consist of online
sessions like this one it will also give
you access to online materials that
mohit pasted links in the chat to some
of the courses that we have online for
your independent learning and then
another aspect will be actually going
through data sets and using those data
sets in the context of analysis so I
just wanted to make sure that it's
fairly straightforward for all of you to
see how this works so let's take a look
at this platform really quickly in the
context of metagenomic analysis so you
can see that the server t - bio info
platform is available for anyone you can
actually request access for research use
or for educational use just by filling
out this form right here but you can
also learn about in the context of this
program about a different several
different areas on the platform are
going to be related so for example here
you can see the amplicon 16s and 18s
ribosomal RNA and we'll take a look now
at just one of the examples here you see
the full sequence assembly of total RNA
and use of that data by mapping it on a
variety of different genomes and you
also have a number of sections here
related to biology so we will actually
cover several of these
actions in the program and we will help
you also find the packages that you
might need if you would like to set up
your own pipeline design your own
pipeline or run this pipeline on your
own server we will also help you
identify packages in our and design the
pipeline to work on urine if you're
interested but in the context of this
program we'll primarily rely on this
platform to understand how to process
the data so let's just take a look
really quickly at a demo now anyone can
request a demo for free and you can look
at how this works really to understand
the concept behind the logic of this
pipeline so if we click on start here we
can read a little bit about what we've
been talking about and here you can see
what the amplicon sequencing of 16s
hypervariable region and you can
understand a little bit about these
conserved regions and really the types
of pipelines are really designed to
address some of the typical challenges
with this data so once we click on ok we
can start the data to pipeline so the
data to pipeline starts with filtering
so you really have to reduce the number
of reads to reduce the noise and you can
read here in each one of the pop ups you
can actually read a fairly detailed
description of what the pipeline does
with explanations for example this is an
explanation of read quality where
certain reads are high quality and
they're kept some readings are low
quality and they are not kept and then
you can see also the output of this step
would be kind of an assessment of
general properties of reads for this
kind of filtering and you can also see
in full description and detailed
tutorial on how to implement so for
example if we go here you can see how to
install this package yourself and this
is something that
is based on a number of packages in our
so anyone can actually install this
pipeline but let's click on ok and now
we will look at several other steps that
help us prepare the organizational
taxonomic units code to use so now we
will go through consensus of owed to use
and really data to pipeline was designed
to improve quality of 16s metagenomic
sequencing so you can see for example
the core data to method correct
substitution and indel errors but
chimeras remain fortunately the accuracy
of the sequence variants after denoising
makes identifying chimeras simpler and
so really it is all about having high
quality data and then once we have high
quality input data we can accurately map
that data to a reference database so
here you can see that this was done by
mapping the data on the Silva database
and you can see that really what the
silver database contains are just
sequences of these hyper variable
regions for a variety of different
species click on OK now we need to
construct the phylogenetic tree so Philo
seek is an R package that allows us to
construct this tree and what we will see
are the actual relationships between the
abundance and the type of level of
organizational taxonomic units that we
have chosen species Island family and
then we can also think of a comparison
between our samples for example we can
think of the composition inside a sample
which is called alpha diversity or the
comparison of two samples or two groups
of samples that could be called beta
diversity so what would be the output
the output of such a pipeline really
will produce a table of abundance where
we will see Oh to use these
organizational taxonomic units across
our samples
we will be able to identify what those
Oh to use represent in the
organizational taxonomic units and then
we will also have the ability to see
composition study the composition of the
microbiome so now we can click on OK and
here we have some outputs and those are
the outputs that we will be studying so
now the question is what is the data
what are these samples how do we
interpret what we have been studying in
the context of the project so that is a
little bit about the practical use of
the platform again the platform itself
is really comprehensive and allows us to
process these types of specific datasets
that we looked at here it also provides
access to some machine learning and data
mining tools has some very useful
utilities for annotation and
visualization of data and also has a lot
of different types of data that you can
work with so really the platform is
designed for multi-omics data and if you
think of the microbiome or if you think
about any microbial data we typically
think of that microbial data in
correlation with some other type of data
and one way to study this is really the
host microbiome interaction how does the
change in composition of the microbiome
affect the response from the host for
example the immune response from the
host or the response in terms of for
example response to treatment right
development of resistance how does it
affect the population scale when we look
at for example spread of an infectious
disease in a geographic endemic how do
we look at that region how do we look at
speed of progression of that disease how
do we look at response from different
types of populations etc so really it's
all about the relationship between the
host and the agent
so going back to our overview here as we
looked at we will study the data to
pipeline and really understand what this
data to pipeline does how do we merge it
with other packages that are going to be
useful for visualization downstream
analysis validation how do we
incorporate the tbo platform provided
interface with other types of tools in
our in excel in other environments where
we can really analyze the data further
to get granularity from our data to be
able to interpret the meaning of that
biologically so in the sense of
understanding what this ribosomal RNA
data can give us we really can look at
several different examples understand
the outputs understand the relationship
between the hyper variable regions and
this type of study that looks at
composition or alpha and beta diversity
so then after we've kind of gone through
the basics right we talked about
different types of microbial communities
we talked about different types of
organisms viruses bacteria fungi and
then we talked about how we can study
different types of sequencing techniques
that allow us to study different aspects
of these microbial populations we will
start thinking about projects and so
what we've done is we've prepared a
number of exemplar projects the American
gut microbiome project called just
simply the American gut is a good
example this is a citizen science
project that was designed to collect
samples from participants like you and I
we can actually all do it at the cost of
99 dollars any one of us can participate
and contribute our samples to this
project really what they did is they
studied the microbe microbiomes from
people from all over the US and I think
now they
expanded to other countries as well we
can have access to that data and people
also answered questionnaires they
answered questionnaires about what they
eat whether is their ethnic background
what is their different psychological
traits so we can start looking at the
type of data that we have available and
how it can help explain some of these
self-reported self-reported phenotypes
we also will look at several other
examples that we've prepared as fully
digested projects for specifically this
program so we'll look at gut-brain axis
again the relationship about between
microbial composition and behavior as
studied in animal models in mice we look
at Ebola and we'll look at tuberculosis
so when we talk about tuberculosis we
really have a project a collection of a
lot of samples there have been recently
a number of studies on microbial
resistance to antibiotics and
tuberculosis is a good example it's a
micro bacterium and it is treated with
different types of treatments in
different locations geographically so we
can collect the type of treatments and
the response to treatment how effective
it was and really study the genomic
compositions of tuberculosis to
understand the relationship between
specific mutations in the genome and the
effect on the treatment we will also
look at Ebola where we will study a
collection of all the Ebola samples from
the 2014 2016 Ebola outbreak in Africa
and we will talk about how the different
positions on the genome once they mutate
as a response to this evolution of viral
adaptation to new populations right if
you think about viruses viruses what is
unique about them is that they have a
short genome and to overcome any kind of
host response
we talk about the immune response if we
talk about the challenges of barriers
between different organs then to adapt
to the responses and to the defense
systems the organism the host organism
has the virus has to mutate different
regions of its genome and as I mentioned
the viruses these types of viruses
really evolved as communities and so we
can look at the community evolution and
understand fitness of different
mutations to study how viral adaptation
can be correlated with for example
geographic distribution or with outcomes
how lethal it is another aspect of these
types of studies a translational value
these studies beyond mechanistic
understanding of how these viruses adapt
and overcome these different defense
mechanisms it is the ability to design
vaccines and so we know that this
outbreak the 2014-2016 outbreak which
was one of the deadliest outbreaks of
Ebola but today we know there's another
outbreak of Ebola it did lead to
development of new vaccines and the
development of new vaccines is actually
very critical for prevention of further
outbreaks and one of the limitations of
the Matan vaccines is this process of
mutation so if we train the organism
immune response on a specific to
recognize specific patterns of proteins
associated with the capsid of the virus
but the virus mutates and then the
capsid doesn't look like that anymore
how do we actually address that problem
right and the problem could be addressed
addressed by finding the most conserved
regions and the ones that are critical
for the viral replication cycle so we'll
talk a little bit about some of these
concepts in the context of this Ebola
project another study is an example of
how we can use genome-wide Association
studies typically studies that are
performed
on larger species but in the context of
bacterial genomes and a good example is
riser bacteria bacteria that forms on
the roots of specific plants and can
have an impact on how these plants can
utilize the resources in the soil around
them transforming them to functional
material for its growth and fruit
production and others so really a
variety of projects ranging from
biomedical to you can say behavioural
right like the gut brain access project
and to agriculture so really we can see
the impact of the study of microbiology
and the study of metagenomics is very
vast now we'll also talk about how to
take data from the public domain
how can one that you know all of you
joining the program how can you find
interesting datasets and understand what
type of sequencing how the data was
generated what is the context of the
phenotypes that we are studying in the
data how do we translate that into a
logical scheme of steps just like we saw
in this pipeline right here right all of
these sections are represented by very
logical step by step sections that you
can utilize to address a very specific
problem so problems of really
understanding the processing of data how
do we prepare data for analysis and to
prepare data for analysis as we saw in
this example we have to understand what
the challenges aren't right so by going
through some of these examples we'll see
what the challenges are we will also
then try to understand the analysis part
this analysis part with finals week
really allows us to study composition
and compare composition between samples
to then interpret how that might affect
for example a certain condition and
that's a correlation
that you need to identify as well so we
will learn about the data inputs we will
talk about the logic of the analysis and
we will talk about the data sets how do
we find those data sets how do we go on
repositories like the NCBI and like some
of these other repositories which have
quite a collection of samples to study
the whole project so just a quick
overview of some of these materials a
lot of the materials that we will be
going through in these online sessions
are going to be focused on supplement
information to the online courses that
you can find here now the courses that
we have here start all the way from free
courses that you can take anybody can
join and take these courses they are
self-guided you can see some of the
topics that have been covered in these
courses and for example this course is
focused on this American gut metagenomic
sequencing project but you also get a
lot more practice and a lot more guided
program by joining the program that we
have online such as this program so it's
very important to understand the
relationship between some of these
different elements that I am showing and
the relationship is that really if you
think of a program that you have access
to somebody to talk to ask questions get
feedback on your project idea really
understand what is it that you want to
do and help you get there that is the
program if you already know what you're
doing and you would like to just
understand how to apply a specific
analysis method to a data set that you
have really what you can get is a
research access to this platform where
you can upload your own data run some of
these analyses get the output and you
will still get feedback from our team on
how to do it better and how to leverage
some of the other resources that might
take awhile to learn about on this whole
platform and the other one is
if you don't feel like you're ready for
a program like this you don't think that
you will be working on your own project
you don't think that you need to
understand the depths of the metagenomic
sequencing and project examples you
would just like to explore what is
metagenomics and how can it be relevant
you can start with a free course for
example one of the courses that you can
start with for free is our course called
introduction to metagenomics
introduction tonight of genomics right
here and in this course we actually
cover a lot of the basics in a very slow
pace that you can adapt to your own
schedule if you have only a little bit
of time you can go through and here you
can see some of the introductory
materials that you can benefit from now
in a second I'll be wrapping up and I
would be happy to address any questions
that you might have about the program
itself or talk about how some of the
previous programs have helped some of
the participants that we've worked with
to achieve their goals so you can learn
a little bit about that we've recently
published a couple of blogs or team put
out on how other participants for
example you can see here dr. Melissa
Bratton from Xavier University in New
Orleans dr. Zeko from Florida
International University you have some
other people that have joined some of
our previous programs and have really
benefited from the research aspects from
the educational aspects and really from
understanding the logic of the analysis
so with that I am going to wrap up the
presentation part of the story and open
up platform for anyone first of all from
our team that would like to add to what
I've covered in this discussion and feel
free to talk about some of the more
technical aspects of the program
including any scheduling questions about
timing for international students or
us-based students as well as some of the
aspects
how the program certificates work you
will get a certificate of participation
based on your activity based on what you
do throughout the program and how many
sessions you join if you have any
questions about the research platform
and how that works we can also talk
about that but also of course all of you
are welcome to continue and stay in
touch with us by email or there is a
chat box on the website itself where you
can just type in your messages
so we'll be happy to answer any of those
questions so I'll pause now and let
anybody else add to what I've said or if
you have any questions please feel free
to type in your question in the chat box
you
mohit would you like to add anything
about the scheduling of the program
yeah Thank You Ilya you know first of
all I would like to thank everyone for
joining this meeting and as Ilya
mentioned that we'll be starting this
started this program today and there
will be another webinar coming up and
henceforth we'll have a lot of more
webinars planned so if I can share my
screen and show you the guide you
through the through the process
you
you
you
you
so we have an organization page with
every program so it's like a classroom
where all the participants can see their
progress we will be describing those in
the next session of as well so I will
just take you to the organization page
and show you the schedule of the program
you
you
you
you
so here is the chat box that Elia was
talking about where you can type in your
questions regarding any queries that you
have so you can just click here and
write about the question and ask us
so so as for the next session we will be
starting on will be talking on 16s
metagenomic sequencing on 1st of
November and on 5th of November we will
be talking about microbiome and hence
again on 8th of November which is
Tuesday will be again talking about the
analysis challenges we will be talking
about short reads as we are o to use and
will be discussing in depth the
pipelines used for the analysis of 16s
metagenomic data and then on Friday will
be discussing mapping on databases and
on 15 will be doing the data to pipeline
that elia just showed you so on 15th
will be taking a break where we will be
letting you do a project so those
projects as mentioned there are multiple
projects in our platform which which is
if we if you can see here you can go
into this and see the projects so you'll
be doing metagenomic projects project
for a month so we will be resuming on
10th of December again so that the
second phase will be more on the
research topics so we will be covering a
bacterial population jiva's analysis of
genome-wide Association studies and then
again on 13th we'll be talking about
viral genome detection in standard RNA
sequence so after that we'll have few
more sessions on phylogenetic analysis
and drug resistance on 28 and we'll be
concluding on on 23rd with a program
with one on one discussion so that would
be all for this overview so I'll give
the stage back to the Ilia or the if
anyone has any question please feel free
to ask us so
just stop the shitty yep
thank you Mohit and yes anyone that
would like to benefit from all of the
aspects of the program again you're
welcome to still register we have
several sessions planned and all of
these sessions are going to be recorded
and shared with all of the participants
that have registered all of you will had
access to the free courses the paid
projects and also a educational license
to the server platform that I just
demonstrated and a lot of guidance and
one-on-one interaction with each one of
our team we have an experienced team
that has been working in metagenomic
data analysis for a while and has
participated in a number of publications
as well as these courses are being
taught in a number of different
organizations around the world where we
have college level and high school level
programs that are also designed for
faculty and to learn about some of these
topics and develop projects with
students together with them so again
feel free to ask any questions if we
don't have any questions we will be
wrapping up this session here in a few
minutes in about five minutes and then
after the session we'll be happy to
share with you some of the recordings
that we have for this session so yes
hello I just wanted to know if I have
registered for another program analysis
Medical Sciences still I have to
register again for this post yeah you
since you're already registered and
another program you can ask for a
discount would be happy to provide that
for you
but this is a separate program that will
cover completely different topics and
will span
two months so just in general to
everyone how these programs work we have
six to eight programs per year focused
on different aspects of bioinformatics
starting from genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics machine
learning for biomedical data and an
introductory program so we can hold
these programs throughout the year and
they're all several months long from one
month to three months and so the payment
that we are requiring for the program is
actually based on one month access to
all these resources and the programs
there is however a an unlimited
subscription that gives you access to
all of the programs and the server
platform to analyze your own data so you
can also inquire about that if you're
interested in kind of pursuing multiple
programs at the same time okay thank you
okay well thank you everyone for joining
again if you have any questions feel
free to reach out to us I believe that
she also posted a link to join the
whatsapp group if you're comfortable
using that for communication we'd be
happy to see you there I'm very excited
about this program to start we'll be
meeting again soon and we are all
excited to see you there
so hopefully you can email us or
continue communicating with us in any
way that's best for you and we'll see
you soon and with that I will end this
presentation and like we mentioned we
will send out the recording of this
session and any other information that
we mentioned during the session by email
and looking forward to seeing you again
soon